wer heutzutage durch einen unfall einen
arm oder ein bein verliert kann trotzdem
beinahe normal weiterleben
die wissenschaft macht extrem große
fortschritte in den bereichen der
bionische prothesen
aber wie lange wird es noch dauern bis
wir jeden einzelnen teil unseres körpers
komplett ersetzen können
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
watson noch vor wenigen jahren bestanden
fast alle prothesen aus nur einem
einzigen material
sie konnten sich weder bewegen noch
haben sie sich an den träger angepasst
sie dienen vielmehr dazu das fehlen
eines körperteils zu verdecken
doch in den letzten 10 bis 15 jahren
haben forscher erfinder und
wissenschaftler riesige sprünge
geschafft hand und beinprothesen können
den träger inzwischen in seinem leben
unterstützen
mit der kraft ihrer gedanken steuern sie
einzelne finger an ihrer hand und können
mit ein bisschen übung jetzt schon fast
alles machen was man mit einer normalen
hand auch machen kann und auf einen
prothesen sind in den letzten jahren
viel besser geworden
in diesem wunderschönen test.org sieht
man wie eine tänzerin nach dem anschlag
auf den boston marathon bei denen sie
ein bein verloren hatte
zum allerersten mal wieder tanzen kann
ersetzt wurde ihr bein durch diesen
extrem fortgeschrittenen bionischen
unterschenkel millionen steht hierbei
für eine mischung aus biologie und
technik und die prothese wurde direkt an
ihr bein angeschlossen und unterstützt
die tänzerin dann wenn sie daran denkt
ihr wein zu bewegen also quasi wie ein
echter muskel aber bionische prothesen
sind auch wenn sie den menschen die sie
brauchen unglaublich helfen nicht
lebensnotwendig die wissenschaft hat es
in den letzten jahren aber auch
geschafft eine erstaunliche anzahl an
organen ersetzbar zu machen
ein herz aus dem 3d drucker kann in
kombination mit den eigenen stammzellen
von alleine schlagen und er setzt so die
lange wartezeit auf ein spenderherz haut
kann inzwischen im labor nachwachsen
solange man noch ein paar wenige eigene
zellen übrig hat gleichzeitig arbeiten
forscher aber auch an einer extrem
widerstandsfähigen künstlichen haut
dieser mann sieht seine frau zum ersten
mal seit seiner erblindung vor über zehn
jahren ein bionische auge dass die
informationen direkt an ihn er
der netzhaut weitergibt erlaubt es ihnen
grobe umrisse seiner umwelt wahrzunehmen
mit ein wenig training soll sich seine
sehfähigkeit sogar noch weiter
verbessern
knochen luftröhren blasen nieren ohren
oder sogar venen alles ist möglich alles
kann ersetzt werden oder für einen
nachwachsen
wissenschaftler konnten im labor sogar
einen gehirn züchten es ist immerhin
vergleichbar mit dem gehirn eines neun
wochen alten fotos allerdings hilft uns
ein künstliches gehören im gegensatz zu
den anderen organen und prothesen
eigentlich überhaupt nichts selbst wenn
man mir in meinem körper ein vollkommen
funktionsfähiges und ausgewachsenes
gewonnen einsetzt ich selber bin ja mit
meinen erinnerungen und meiner
persönlichkeit ich bin hier immer noch
tot
es scheint also so als wären geistige
krankheiten in der zukunft vielleicht
das letzte was sie noch zwischen uns und
die theoretische unsterblichkeit stellt
denn selbst wenn wir wirklich alle der
tausende noch offenen fragen über
unseren körper irgendwann beantworten
können und selbst wenn wir es schaffen
jeden einzelnen teil unseres körpers
irgendwann ersetzbar zu machen
da könnte man natürlich trotzdem noch
sterben durch unfälle oder zum beispiel
durch die einwirkung anderer menschen
trotzdem denke ich dass es noch eine
frage der zeit ist bis sich der erste
mensch freiwillig eine komplett gesunder
hand amputieren lässt weil eine
bionische hand stärker oder
anpassungsfähiger ist und auch wenn sehr
viele der möglichkeiten die ich gerade
angesprochen habe noch immer in der test
phase stecken und noch jahre wenn nicht
jahrzehnte benötigen um sie für uns alle
zugänglich zu machen sollten sie jetzt
schon ein paar fragen stellen zum
beispiel kann man ab einem gewissen
zeitpunkt von mensch zu maschine werden
oder bleibe ich auf jeden fall immer ein
mensch so lange ich mein gehirn benutzt
oder müssten die regierungen die
geburtenrate kontrollieren weil immer
weniger menschen sterben und wir deshalb
irgendwann zu viele werden vielleicht
sogar so sehr dass es nur noch sehr
wenigen menschen vielleicht sogar nur
sehr intelligenten menschen erlaubt ist
kinder zu bekommen
so ähnlich ist es zum beispiel bei
enders game und was ist eigentlich mit
armen menschen all diese operationen
werden auch in zukunft noch eine menge
geld kosten
hat jeder mensch ein recht auf
unsterblichkeit oder kann sich diesen
luxus nur die elite leisten ist ein
menschenleben mehr wert wenn ein mensch
im durchschnitt viele hundert jahre alt
wird und sollte mord deswegen stärker
bestraft werden weil man jetzt um einen
mehr potentielle lebensjahre zerstört
und weil zum anderen 15 jahre gefängnis
eigentlich gar nicht so viel ist wenn
man selber mehrere
100 jahre alt wird ich selber möchte
eigentlich nicht wirklich anmuten diese
fragen zu beantworten aber vielleicht
haben ihre meinung zu dem thema wie
würde sich unsere gesellschaft verändern
wenn wir menschen nicht mehr eines
natürlichen todes sterben können
schreibt man auf jeden fall unten in die
kommentare ich bin sehr gespannt auf
eure ideen wenn euch enders game
interessiert mir persönlich hat der film
überraschender weise gut gefallen
das vorspiel dazu könnt ihr kostenlos
als geschenk bekommen wenn ihr euch bei
anne will einen account erstellt das
ganze ist komplett kostenlos keine
versteckten kosten
link dazu unten in der video
beschreibung genauso wie meine quellen
die ich für das video hier heute benutzt
habe und auch der test ob mit der
tänzerin jetzt auch dabei ansonsten
findet ihr hier noch meine beiden
letzten episoden von watson und ich sagt
vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal